ukraine is putting the squeeze on russia
on several fronts including inside a
courtroom the war crimes trial of a
russian soldier accused of killing a
ukrainian civilian in the early days of
the war got underway friday it is
expected to resume next week in its
fight against russia's offensive line in
the east ukraine apparently managed to
disable a key bridge this comes as
ukraine says russian forces are pulling
out of a major city after weeks of heavy
bombardment adding to that finland wants
to join nato and sweden is likely to
follow at the same time a top ukrainian
official says the direction of the war
could change charlie dagda is in west
central ukraine in the city of
vignitsa this morning with the very
latest charlie good morning
good morning to you dana this doesn't
look like much of a war zone here
because here it's it's really not people
are coming back out onto the streets are
no longer hiding out in bunkers and it's
kind of returning to normal meanwhile
ukraine's top intelligence chief has
made two bold statements overnight one a
coup to remove president putin is
already underway two russia will be
defeated by the end of the year
a grim tally of the human costs on both
sides of putin's war recovery teams have
been collecting the bodies of russian
soldiers from the battlefield body bags
loaded onto refrigerated box cars for
their final journey home if the kremlin
agrees to take them
while those captured now face a
courtroom for war crimes the trial of 21
year old russian sergeant vadim
shishamaran got underway in the capital
accused of shooting an unarmed 62 year
old man on a bike
leaving him for dead
ukrainian troops have successfully
driven back attacks in ukraine's second
largest city of park eve but shelling to
the north of the city killed two
civilians and destroyed a humanitarian
center
everyone was preparing for breakfast as
usual the relative of one victim said
then there were explosions and i fell to
the ground when i ran there he was lying
at this place and both of his legs were
gone
the russians have shown no mercy at the
steel plant in mary opal continuing to
pummel what's left of the facility while
hundreds of ukrainian fighters remain
trapped below with no way out thousands
of ground forces in mariupol have been
redeployed these rushing backs separate
as seen on the move north to the eastern
donbass region where the conflict has
become a bloody stalemate with
casualties climbing by the day the
ukrainian military released drone video
purporting to show destroyed pontoon
bridges and battered russian tanks and
armored vehicles that had tried to cross
a key river
unable to pierce through ukrainian
defenses the russian military has been
unleashing artillery and airstrikes
raining down on civilian areas like this
neighborhood in bakumut we visited
furious residents demanding to know why
their homes were targeted and why they
weren't getting any help putting their
homes and lives back together
now standing next to that crater it's
hard to know exactly what the russians
were aiming for unless the aim was to
spread terror but the residents that we
spoke to said they have no intention of
leaving
michelle
yes especially with no military targets
in sight charlie dagetta in vignettes
ukraine thank you